good morning good morning to noble forum
and this press conference for the
announcement of this year's Nobel Prize
in Physiology or medicine my name is
Thomas Perlman and on the Secretary of
the Nobel assembly
I will first read the announcement in
Swedish followed by English and we will
then present some background to the
price and open up for questions
Nobel efficient lira Karolinska
Institutet aura dogmas lived at Nobel
Prize in Physiology or medicine or
tortoise and hooked on scarlet d-las lee
gamelon Geoffrey C Hall Michael rosebush
aqua Michael BB young for the era's
objector or molecular mechanics mal son
still USC record is gripped the Nobel
assembly at Karolinska Institutet has
today decided to award the 2017 Nobel
Prize in Physiology or medicine jointly
to Jeffrey C Hall Michael rosebush and
Michael W young for their discoveries on
molecular mechanisms controlling the
circadian rhythm here are the three
laureates Jeffrey hall was born in New
York and performed his seminal work at
Brandel Brandeis University he's now
retired and lives in Cambridge in Boston
Michael rosebush is was born in Oklahoma
City and performed his prize-winning
studies also at Brandeis University
where he still on the faculty and
finally Michael yang was born in Miami
and did his work at Rockefeller
University in New York where he saw
where he also remains on the faculty I
will now describe the discoveries behind
this year's award
so this year's price concerns the
circadian rhythm the word circadian
originates from the latin word cerca
meaning around and Diaz meaning day but
in a way it is actually about astronomy
ever since the emergence of life on
Earth about four billion years ago
evolving life-forms had to adapt to the
rotation of our planet this ability to
prepare for the regular daily
fluctuations is crucial for all
life-forms but how is this possible this
year's Nobel laureates have been
studying this fundamental problem and
solved the mystery of how an inner clock
in most of our cells in our bodies can
anticipate daily fluctuations between
night and day to optimize our behavior
and physiology this existence of an
inner clock was first described already
in the 18th century the French
astronomer de Muro studied the mimosa
plant that opens its leaves towards the
Sun during day that closes at dusk de
Muro asked what would happen if the
plant was exposed exposed to constant
darkness and he found that even then for
several days the leaves continued to
follow the regular 24-hour daily rhythm
in the 20th century it was established
that also other plants and animals
including rodents and humans have their
own biological flaws following the daily
circadian rhythm studies of the clock in
fruit flies show that many different
behaviors are controlled by the clock
fruit flies are really excellent model
organisms for studies of genetics and in
the 1970s a mutation that affected the
Flies daily rhythm was identified the
mutated locust was called period but how
did the mutation affect the internal
clock
this year's laureates they wish to peek
inside the clock and figure out how it
actually works a first breakthrough came
in 1984 when Jeff Hall in collaboration
with Michael rosebush and Michael yang
working independently were able to
isolate the period gene now the
scientists could begin to disentangle
the cellular wheels and cogs of a clock
machinery Jeff Hall and Michael rosebush
showed that the period protein itself
was cycling and peaked during night and
was low during day in 1990 they showed
that the period mRNA also oscillated as
shown on this slide and accumulated
several hours before the period protein
these and other important observations
led to a brilliant idea for how the
clock works by a feedback control
mechanism the idea was shown to be
correct and in the next few slides I
will show how it actually works when the
period gene is active period mRNA is
made the period mRNA is transported to
the cell's cytoplasm where period
protein is made when period protein
accumulates the protein moves into the
cell's nucleus with blocks the activity
of its own gene when the gene is blocked
no more RNA can be made period protein
levels will decrease and the gene will
no longer be blocked and the production
of mRNA can start all over again and the
cycle can continue but it remained
unclear how the period protein could
accumulate in the nucleus to inhibit the
gene this problem was solved when
Michael yang discovered the second gene
called timeless that is also critical
for
clock this is shown in this experiment
the top diagram shows how peered mRNA is
cycling over several days in normal
flies the bottom diagram shows that the
cycling was disrupted when the timeless
gene had been inactivated but how did
the timeless protein affect the period
gene additional experiments showed that
timeless protein bound to the period
protein and together they entered the
cell nucleus where they could inhibit
the pierre-jean it was also critical to
understand how the speed of the
oscillations can be controlled Michael
Young identified yet another protein
called double time or DBT this protein
was shown to slow down those the
accumulation of the period protein which
explained how the oscillation can be
adjusted to more closely match a 24-hour
cycle Jeff Hall and Michael rosebush
showed that two additional proteins
clock and cycle activated appeared gene
in fruit flies so with all these
groundbreaking discoveries by the three
laureates an elegant feedback control
mechanism for the biological clock had
finally been unraveled we now recognize
that biological clocks function by these
same principles in other animals
including in ourselves in humans most of
our cells in our bodies have these
clocks our inner clock adapts our
physiology to the dramatically different
phases of the day and regulates many
critical functions such as behavior
hormone levels sleep body temperature
and metabolism we do not feel well when
there is a temporary mismatch between
our external environment and internal
biological clock for example when we
experience jetlag
studies have also indicated that chronic
misalignment between our lifestyles and
the clock is associated with increased
risk for various diseases since the
paradigm shifting discoveries by whole
rosebush and young circadian biology has
developed into a highly dynamic research
field with vast implications for our
health and well-being here they are
again
Jeffrey hall Michael rosebush and
Michael Young this is the end of the
presentation and I would now wish to
present our expert panel who would be
happy to respond if there are questions
so at the far end we have professor
Julian Serrat who is a member of the
Nobel Committee in center we have Anna
Weddell who is the chair of the Nobel
Committee and on her side we have
professor Carlos Ibanez who is also a
member of the Nobel Committee so please
if there are any questions this go ahead
there must be at least one question okay
please go ahead
we we are usually not afraid of calling
them about this and I was able to get
Hall or Michael Ross Bosch and Jeffrey
hall but I haven't reached Michael Young
so they just got the news I first got
hold of Mike the rosebush and he was
silent and then he said you are kidding
me
is there any other question yeah I'm
that resist go ahead about the dynamics
of this system so if one were to change
the cycle to like six hours instead of
24 hours for humans for somebody or
chicken they're being kept in in very
short cycles what happens with this
system does it adapt to very short I
think I'll ask are not to respond to
that question well we know that there
are in rare cases there are humans who
have a little bit altered length of the
period not as you described six hours
but a little bit shorter and they get
sleep problems we don't know of any
drastic disruptions in humans of the
clock there are of course animal
experiments and if you disrupt the clock
in animals you will get effect on
metabolism and on various physiological
parameters but in humans it's not really
possible to do those kinds of
experiments but are there any treatments
or possible treatments for Taurus sleep
disorders that could be based on this
right well an obvious answer would be a
melatonin which is a hormone that is
secreted before we go to sleep and that
it can also be used to
for those kinds of problems and some
people even use it for jet lag and also
if you're blind for instance you know
your rhythm will still be going but it
will be out of sync with the misaligned
it will be free running then it's it
will not be entrained by light and then
you can use similar compounds to
melatonin to try to adjust did you hear
me here's one question please go ahead
hello i'm from chinese media green post
and channel Radio International my
understanding of this prize is in
physiology right so can you tell us how
how long have you or how did you find
them and what is their contribution to
mankind
I'll ask Carlos about us to respond to
that question
how we found them our mechanism is based
on nominations from different parts of
the academic community and institutions
universities other scientists and then
these scientists have been nominated by
these other members of the Academy
community and research community and
then that's how we found them our work
is directed by the nominations that we
get we are aware of interesting fields
but we can only follow up nominations
from the scientific community and then
we investigate whether the discoveries
married this price and that's how we
found them the contribution to humankind
is the discovery of a fundamental
mechanism underlying very important
aspects of physiology how our cells can
keep time did I answer your question
[Music]
okay Esther here's one question I've got
a one question I'm Fred from China's
national Xinhua news agency regarding -
this is discovery do you think this
discovery by the scientists can is can
solve the problems especially that we
encounter in the Nordic countries where
you've got long dark winter days the
people tend to have depression and is it
this discovery actually shedding lights
- solving the problem to boost you know
people's energy could Julian ask the
question was how this discovery might
solve the problem of how people cope
with extreme dark changes in darkness or
sunlight and I think what it can do is
raise awareness to the importance of
proper sleep hygiene and the importance
of really making certain that we allow
ourselves to you know go to bed at an
hour that's suitable I guess for many of
us it's around you know between 10
o'clock or so even if the sun is shining
on midsummer day and it probably helps
us to be aware of the fact that we need
to be in a dark environment to get the
best sleep and that we shouldn't be
afraid of using our alarm clock even
when it's the darkest times of the year
so I think what it can do is help raise
awareness okay
Esther ma else who is interested in ask
answering asking a question
they go wrong they go wrong so frugal
person schedule browser Adorama's broke
only Florida you're also the school
afford row your interview sermon as the
Harlem and in rebels Claudia semana
Shanthi loss on Gore who have set on the
use on the use dilemma worked on the
door not the knee in readin goober also
helped them still threat of each traffic
tourism use and a food chatter Gore
would improve our car welded McGee over
official Aguirre or the Maharaja can
halt first thought mechanism Alfred
hidden Hokkien funghi receiver clock
convenes in Assam are lavoris Eric
rotten we evaluate victi for Valdez
Manya processor
okay if there are no more questions to
ask I know many of you are looking for
interviews so we can go ahead with that
so with that I would like to close this
conference and thank you all for coming
thank you
[Music]
professor Oliver they'll share the Nobel
Committee could you describe to us what
is circadian rhythm so circadian it rise
from the lighter so circuits around and
day is they and this is the daily rhythm
we have to anticipate and adapt to the
dramatically different conditions during
day and night that arise from the
rotation of the earth the three
laureates is what problem have been
solved for a long time that there are
diurnal or circadian rhythms but how it
worked wasn't unknown at all and it was
debated for a long time whether it was a
response to external signals or
something endogenous and they before
they started their work it was
understood that it was endogenous and it
was even understood that single genes
could influence the circadian rhythm but
nothing was known about the mechanism
and there were different hypotheses but
they found out if the mechanism that
controls the machinery of the clock so
he turned to the discovery
what were the key findings and who did
what so first of all they studied they
used the fruit fly as a model system and
before their work there has been a
classic experiment by Benson and Konopka
they had used the fruit fly to ask can
you identify mutants that arise due to
mutations in single genes so that was
sort of a basis before our laureates
started their work and they took
advantage of that because the the gene
wasn't known there were mutant strains
known who had long or short or no rhythm
at all that were known to map to the
same locus so the laureates useless
prize and went on to isolate the gene
and to determine what gene it was but
that didn't prove the mechanism either
so what they then did was experiments to
understand the function of the system by
this gene and then several others at the
in sequential experiments why is
circular rhythm important so we need the
circadian clock to anticipate the daily
changes not only adapt but anticipate so
it's so there are dramatically different
conditions during day and night and we
need to be very active in the day and
other processes need to take place
during night and evolutionary it's been
a very great advantage to take to use
the only critical lights hours where
minutes of the day for instance if
you're at if you're hunting you need to
be acted or if you're hunted you need to
run and hide so you need to be prepared
and take advantage of and be that one
step before the the environment that's
why we need it is this kind of clock is
it this is it all ourselves we know that
most of ourselves have this clock and we
also know we knew before these
discoveries that there is a central
clock in the brain that controls the
rhythm and then later it was found that
it we also have them in other parts of
our body but it's the it's actually the
mechanism that the low rates have
elusively
it's an auto regulatory self-sustained
inhibitory feedback loop complicated if
you should describe this what they found
there there was a waterfall in an
accessible wave would it be yes it's a
metaphor one could you know the clock is
a method very easy but but the mechanism
it's a little bit difficult but it's an
oscillator so you build up a substance
and then when the substance is there
it's one turn soft it sounds production
and then it can start over again so that
it becomes an oscillation
so a negative feedback of its own
synthesis that's the best I can do like
an hourglass when the lower part is full
of sound and it's time to turn around
doesn't really shut up its own synthesis
so it's hard to find something similar
actually so an oscillator and the
mechanism for the oscillator by shutting
off its own synthesis in a regulated way
so it becomes self sustained autonomous
prices for Physiology or medicine so
what are the medical indications this
huge field of chronobiology chrono
medicine it's really exploding it's a
fascinating area but in humans most data
on specific diseases are so far
correlations so we don't really have the
firm evidence to postulate the circadian
clock does this or that when it comes to
disease there are some examples there
are sleep phase disorders where you
actually have mutations in the core some
of the core clock genes and then you
have a shorter or a longer face and that
causes problems with sleep that's a
solid thing but in humans apart from
that there are lots of correlations
there's more known of course in animal
models where you can disrupt the clock
and then see effects
another example is jet lag of course but
that's not really a disease but that
indicates that when we're misaligned so
that our inner clock does not match or
is misaligned to the environment then we
really feel bad but then of course
there's a lot of interest in trying to
understand if our lifestyle today with
social jetlag has implications for
disease and that's the reality started
but so far mainly correlations sometimes
you feel hella bad weather
wintertime whenever in Sweden and the
darkness how much would one coat how one
Charcot well that's a big question well
I what I can say regarding that is that
there's so many things that we need to
understand and also be the core
machinery it's a lot more complex but
the concept is the same but we now know
that there are more factors regulating
and stabilizing there are interconnected
loops and there are mechanisms for
entrainment so you adjust the clock
mechanisms for synchronizing clocks
throughout the body and output
mechanisms so other genes are sort of
hitchhiking on the system and controlled
by the same mechanism and all of this is
really really dynamic and we're learning
so much so although these all of these
implication questions what it means were
help that really remains to be familial
down now and they have provided tools
for that by understanding this
mechanisms we now have a way forward to
address these issues laureates three
Americans
my cojones he was born in 1945 he worked
very closely together with micro spa
they have been working together since
the mid 70s and they are about the same
age might ever splash is one year
younger Palmas retired but my rosebushes
very active sale and Michael Young is
also an American and he worked
independently there have also had some
collaborations but he's at Rockefeller
University he's also spent a very long
career at Rockefeller and he's still
very active finally has Nobel Committee
you've been able to reach you know the
Lord's yes sir so our Secretary General
Professor Thomas Pearlman he has reached
rose fashion hall but he's not been able
to reach you Michael Young yet question
what do you think is the best about this
price well it's such a fundamental prize
it's a detailed molecular mechanism but
it explains how we are as after to the
planets I think it's a very fundamental
thing and it's important for so many
things
and it's open so many questions been
enable so many questions
okay